u.s companies like apple are
increasingly shifting production from
china amid political tensions and
repeated covet 19 lockdowns a new study
indicates german firms are on the whole
going in a very different direction
according to the cologne institute of
economic research german direct
investment in the first half of this
year is already double than what it was
for the entire 2010 climbing from just
over five
to
over 10 billion dollars in a decade
again that's just the first half of this
year
china is germany's largest trading
partner and it accounts for more than
seven percent of all german exports for
more on this let's bring in jurgen matis
he's the chief economist at the german
economic institute in cologne
welcome to the program jurgen
you're one of the authors of this report
now at the same time you say this
massive investment by german companies
in china is the wrong way to go why
well obviously because
the political relation to china has
changed in recent years
and especially
the russian ukraine war and the threats
of china to invade taiwan
change
also the environment for international
trade
now we have to understand most of these
investment decisions haven't made a long
time ago so
those are not spur of the moment uh
investments
no of course that's that's perfectly
true
um but we still see
that um
also from from surveys of german firms
in in china that there is an increasing
tendency to localize business in china
and to do even more in china and um our
fear is that the risk exposure of some
german firms might be so big that in
case of
taiwan invasion and sanctions from the
west these firms could come under
pressure and that um the the fallout
from that could in the end land on the
taxpayer here in germany um if a bailout
would be necessary do you do you see
that uh german companies ill-prepared in
the case of a chinese attack on taiwan
and subsequent
sanctions
well obviously we don't look into
balance sheet and the exact
business
activities of individual firms we look
at the macro level
so our demand is um it's the business
and the responsibility of every business
leader to um put up um
the china business in a way um that it
can be closed down without bringing down
the total the company as a whole and
this is the um direction i think with
that also um german policy makers seem
to to um want to go to because it's
important to note that
the german government is in the process
of writing a new china strategy and we
see some indications that significant
change will
come about by that
now you say german companies in china
should basically
scale down their investment there their
exposure there
to what tune exactly how big a share
should the chinese market be when it
comes to doing business for german
companies around the world
well that obviously depends on on every
every business
i think it's
you also have to differentiate it's
maybe in some parts not only
doing a bit less with china but doing
more with others
there are other large asian markets that
develop dynamically like
india like indonesia thailand malaysia
from the eu perspective we need free
trade agreements with these countries in
order to develop them as a partner for
german for the german economy be it on
the import side as well as on the export
side
jorg matas of the german economic
institute thank you for your thoughts
thank you